grazie corrado grazie agli organizzatori
di questo evento
e a voi che siete qui presenti oggi sono
qui per parlare di intuizione cioè per
parlare per usare parole per qualcosa
che appartiene alla sfera del vedere
etimologicamente intuire significa
vedere letteralmente vedere dentro forse
per vedere quel che l'apparenza del
quotidiano la consolidata levigata
apparenza del quotidiano non ci non ci
consente di penetrare e dunque di
comprendere con uno sguardo più ampio
forse più profondo e migliore e dunque
le parole sono inutili
come si può con le parole produrre il
vedere
beh la vista e per la filosofia un senso
privilegiato custodisce fra l'altro
sempre etimologicamente l'origine delle
idee ma l'udito lo è altrettanto
l'uomo è altrettanto essenzialmente
logos parola logos parola che prepara a
esorta a l'azione la trasformazione la
capacità di generare le idee che
diventano azione e dunque le parole non
sono mai soltanto parole soltanto parole
parole fra noi come forse può ricordare
qualcuno dei meno giovani presenti in
questa sala purché siano parole ben
spese come quello come quelle che
normalmente sono le proprie normalmente
sono le parole che si spendono
dialogando insieme
partirò per questa breve illustrazione
dalla definizione che abbiamo letto
tutti sul sito
di questo evento l'intuizione è una
esperienza attraverso la quale la mente
accede di colpo ad un aspetto diverso
della realtà dunque sono tre gli
elementi sui quali soffermare la nostra
attenzione
il primo è la mente l'intuizione
riguarda la mente
beh evidentemente tutto ciò che accade
all uomo passa per la mente in qualche
modo accade nella mente le sensazioni
prima ancora dei pensieri le passioni
l'amore l'odio l'amicizia tutto accade
nella mente anche se continuiamo a dire
e continueremo probabilmente a farlo che
ci innamoriamo con il cuore
sappiamo che questo in realtà accade
nella nostra mente in qualche area del
nostro del nostro cervello ma dire mente
in questo caso significa dire qualcosa
di importante significa comunque dire
che l'intuizione a che fare non con
l'emozione di un momento ma con la forza
la solidità
se volete anche il pathos motivazionale
di una forma di conoscenza
quando abbiamo una intuizione sentiamo
appunto e vengo al secondo elemento di
accedere di colpo e il terzo elemento ad
un aspetto diverso
potremmo anche aggiungere nuovo più
profondo come dicevo della realtà di
colpo l'intuizione accade sempre sul
sito
leggiamo che non la possiamo produrre
arriva forse non sappiamo neppure da
dove ritornerò su questa affermazione
per correggerla
fra poco ma certamente il carattere
dell'immediatezza locke distingueva per
questo la conoscenza dimostrativa dalla
conoscenza intuitiva
è qualcosa che afferriamo tutta insieme
e che diventa generatrice di pensieri e
di azioni piuttosto che essere il
risultato di pensieri almeno
apparentemente e qui si può generare un
equivoco sul quale fra poco tornerò
questa esperienza della mente che accade
di colpo e un'esperienza che apre ad un
aspetto diverso della realtà
l'intuizione serve per cambiare per
rinnovare per farci comprendere qualcosa
che prima semplicemente non vedevamo
nella storia della filosofia questo
risale addirittura alle origini stesse
di questa esperienza umana e a platone e
aristotele appunto alle idee non
soltanto a qualcosa che è diverso ma
qualcosa che è l'essenza del reale
c'è un quarto elemento per il quale
attingo comunque al deposito ricco del
sapere filosofico sul quale occorre
credo soffermare la nostra attenzione
ed è questo l'immediatezza
dell'intuizione dipende certamente dalla
presenza dell'oggetto che intuiamo quale
che sia la natura di questo oggetto
questo oggetto in qualche modo ci si
impone ma l'intuizione non è mai
soltanto questo
l'intuizione è anche un rapporto
particolare fra il soggetto e l'oggetto
cioè nell'intuizione ci sentiamo avvolti
e coinvolti in un modo speciale
quando abbiamo una intuizione che merita
di essere definita tale sta accadendo
qualcosa di importante per noi e sta
accadendo in
un modo che non è necessariamente quello
della ricezione passiva kant distingueva
per questo fra è tutta una tradizione
a seguire fra l'intuizione sensibile
l'intuizione intellettuale a
sottolineare nella seconda in
particolare questo elemento di
un'attività per la quale noi diventiamo
e ci sentiamo protagonisti di qualcosa
già agostino in questo senso diceva che
io vedo queste cose perché ci sono esse
esistono perché tu riferendosi a dio le
vedi dunque quando abbiamo una
intuizione che si tratti dell'artista
che si tratti dell'imprenditore che è
stato prima evocato o che si tratti del
politico
noi siamo mossi alla azione e ci
sentiamo protagonisti è una scintilla di
attività è una scintilla di attività e
dunque l'intuizione avere intuito
comunemente viene riconosciuto come un
talento che offre qualcosa di più a chi
lo possiede che cosa offre di più beh fa
vedere più lontano fa vedere quello che
ancora non è stato visto fa vedere
abbiamo detto d'un colpo quindi accorcia
i tempi
il che in questo tempo pare essere un
grande vantaggio
e in più e in più ci apre un percorso
per creare qualcosa di nuovo per
trasformare la realtà per nuove forme
dell'umano
e bello essere intuitivi ma attenzione
a ciascuna di queste opportunità
corrispondono dei rischi quando pensiamo
di vedere lontano forse abbiamo una
visione che è un miraggio
forse siamo soltanto dei visionari
forse ci stiamo illudendo la nostra
opera d'arte sarà brutta la nostra
impresa sarà un fallimento
la nostra azione politica non produrrà
nessun effetto addirittura produrrà
l'effetto opposto a quello che avevamo
programmato perché avevamo avuto una
grande intuizione e ancora fare in
fretta va bene ma l'impazienza può
condurre a molti errori e le cose
importanti richiedono tempo per essere
realizzate e infine siamo sicuri che la
cosa diversa che vediamo l'essenza che
pensiamo di scorgere sia tale perché
l'abbiamo vista a noi e noi siamo i
privilegiati che hanno avuto questo
accesso speciale ad una visione diversa
l'intuizione può essere anche la
tentazione del solipsismo e allora
vorrei condividere con voi tre tesi che
illustra attraverso altrettanti esempi
la prima tesi è questa
non pretendo che vi accompagnino per la
lunga giornata insomma ecco sono
soltanto le parole che io mi sento di
spendere sull'intuizione e sono felice
di condividerle con voi oggi la prima
tesi e dunque questa non è vero che
l'intuizione accade per caso
diffidate di coloro che vi incitano ad
essere parlo soprattutto i giovani ad
essere intuitivi
perché tanto l'intuizione costa meno
fatica ci sediamo ad aspettare che
arrivi l'illuminazione non sappiamo da
dove viene dicevo non la possiamo
produrre noi beh in fondo se non succede
niente non sarà stata colpa mia
no chi di voi ha visto batman begins
posso chiedere di alzare la mano è un
bellissimo film peraltro chi di voi ha
letto la ericsson of trading andy
novalis lo temeva lo temeva ma il fiore
azzurro che si trova in batman begins e
nello heinrich von after dinger ci dice
qualcosa di importante e i bei film
servono anche a questo
per ricordarci qualcosa di importante
che è rimasto sepolto in una tradizione
che purtroppo non arriva più sulle
scrivanie di molti ci dice che ciò che
riassume il senso di un esperienza e la
sua ricchezza e che ci rende capaci di
intervenire sulla realtà per
trasformarla non è qualcosa che si
coglie con il leggero gesto di un attimo
è qualcosa che richiede una lunga
preparazione una lunga esperienza melo
lasciate dire la fatica dello studio ed
ecco la pazienza e il lavoro sono capaci
di avere intuizioni che lasciano il
segno
prima di tutto coloro che hanno avuto la
pazienza e si sono sottoposti al lavoro
di un lungo percorso per guadagnare uno
sguardo diverso seconda tesi le grandi
intuizioni anche se poi sono spesso le
intuizioni di un singolo individuo di
una singola grande personalità
sono le intuizioni
che fecondano un terreno che è il
terreno comune dove viviamo insieme dove
ci scambiamo i nostri punti di vista
qualche settimana fa è morto
tragicamente robin williams dunque
lasciatemi citare il professor john
keating dell'attimo fuggente che sale
sulla cattedra per invitare i suoi
studenti a non aver paura di diversi
punti di vista
sapete qual è il limite però di questa
splendida dimostrazione della verità del
pluralismo che genera intuizioni che
genera poesia e molte altre cose
proposta da john keating robin williams
beh il fatto che come tutti i professori
per far capire che ci sono punti di
vista diversi
ebbene salire sulla cattedra anzi
addirittura a salire in piedi sulla
cattedra ma i professori questo è un
gesto che viene molto spontaneo
attenzione c'è anche il punto di vista
dal basso
qui non ci sono scalini a sufficienza ma
provate a sedervi per terra ea guardare
chi vi sta davanti
naturalmente salite anche sulla cattedra
e salite c in piedi ma non abbiate paura
dei diversi punti di vista ci si allena
ad intuire meglio e ad intuire di più e
più lontano terza e ultima idea
siate gelosi del valore dell'intuizione
così come è stata descritta da corrado
già nelle sue parole introduttive perché
solo l'intuizione comunque e lo dico
adesso dopo che vi ho esortato a pensare
che l'intuizione non nasce per caso e
che l'intuizione non è
una torre d'avorio nella quale ci
rinchiudiamo per con per contemplare
narcisisticamente i nostri successi o le
nostre aspirazioni di successo ma adesso
lo dico l'intuizione vi salverà dal
conformismo solo l'intuizione la
capacità la passione di coltivare la
ricerca del nuovo di cercare un altro
punto di vista vi salverà dal
conformismo vi renderà davvero capaci di
creare qualcosa di nuovo
e allora lasciatemi concludere leggendo
questa citazione che riguarda il mondo
dell'università quello nel quale in
fondo ci troviano un signore vi dirò fra
poco chi ha scritto qualche tempo fa
quanto segue attenzione giovani studiosi
giovani ricercatori perché la pressione
a pubblicare molto in breve tempo rende
gli iscritti accademici più fiacchi meno
coraggiosi e più tecnici dal momento che
i membri più giovani del corpo
accademico preferiscono scrivere quel
che sanno essere accettabile dalle
riviste e dalla stampa accademiche
questo non lo ha scritto un rosicone
della vqr la valutazione della qualità
della ricerca è per compensare se stesso
del suo fallimento
lo ha scritto kerry lewis che è stato
per otto anni preside della harvard
college in un libro che si intitola
eccellenza senza anima
ecco l'intuizione ci aiuta a non cadere
in questo equivoco lari la semplice
ripetizione del passato e questo è un
invito che mi sento di rivolgere a tutti
i giovani presenti anche ai colleghi e
ai miei coetanei perché da questo punto
di vista soprattutto nella nostra
università
nell'università di tor vergata
nell'università italiana
caro corrado non sono così sicuro che si
abbia a cuore l'intuizione nel senso che
adesso ho detto forse una battaglia
quasi persa ma il fatto che ci siano dei
giovani che ci invitano a riflettere
sull'intuizione mi fa sperare che sia
ancora almeno aperta e almeno nel nostro
corso di laurea in filosofia noi la
riteniamo tale chi visita il nostro sito
troverà che abbiamo deciso di
raccogliere i nostri sforzi
sotto una intuizione di giorgio gaber
con tutte le libertà che avete volete
anche la libertà di pensare e abbiate la
pazienza il lavoro che già erano le
intuizioni perché sarete anche più
liberi di pensare
grazie per la vostra pazienza e agli
organizzatori che ci danno questa bella
occasione per stare insieme